talk of how there's been a food
Revolution and food so brilliant now in
Britain David Mitchell you disagree well
my feeling is that at
in this episode
you'll like this
in this country we are at heart Eaters
of sandwiches at our keyboards
we just we're not there are many in in
Italy in France they really care about
every meal they have here we do like now
and again to have a massively poshed
meal but most of the meals we just think
it
a meeting at two I just have some crisps
and a sort of incredibly soggy baguette
that would make a French Baker kill
himself
and that's for most meals what we do but
we now do have oh no you can go
occasionally to a astronomically
expensive restaurant where you can't
really talk because they need to
describe the tiny dish in about 400
words and it takes much less time to eat
it wow that that said that's a sort of
um that's a bit of a recreational
activity now in this country because I
think I'm I don't want to speak for you
Kylie I think you enjoy the long
description of the tiny thing
okay
[Applause]
Am I Wrong uh yeah yes you do like yes
well uh yeah I like I like the
description
of the it's part of the show yeah you
like to know how it was made how it was
sourced yeah
[Music]